I'm going to be photoshopped into
Hawaiian ideal beauty standards
moccasins beauty ideals Thai beauty
standards in Hawaii today beauty ideals
would have to be long hair tanned skin
and an athletic body type box money's
you know the almond eyes you have to be
hairless you have to be tall that still
has the figure of like a woman growing
up like I would watch a lot of Thai
dramas a lot of them would be very like
light skinned big eyes really slender
and skinny and petite watching Bollywood
growing up - like everyone's so
beautiful and light skinned and I don't
look like them exactly because they have
almond eyes and I have smaller eyes for
a Pakistani girl I'm not like the
stereotypical like hula dancer I have
the fair skin my hair isn't black or
super dark brown my skin is a little bit
darker so my friend would give me
whitening soap to actually widen up I'm
excited to see what I'd look like you
know five inches more my mom has really
tan skin and that's something that I
always really like I'm really excited
and curious to see myself being photo
shop into a whole different frame
[Music]
I'm excited to see myself Photoshop I'm
more anxious I think than nervous I'm
scared like it's gonna be something that
I really like and but I won't be able to
achieve it oh my gosh I'm so tan it
looks like I'm on one of those snapchat
filters I feel like it is the Polynesian
version of a Western Beauty type oh my
god
I'm so thin it looks like I'm looking at
a whole different person seeing like the
before and after the before is me I have
like small eyes I have like a big smile
and then seeing the afters like this
like refined woman it's exactly like a
Barbie like no one can live up to a
Barbie standards I'm not really used to
seeing myself with dark hair but I
really like it my skin is different
I have injections in my lips and bigger
boobs and it's not me even though it's a
picture of me I noticed like a nose job
here
it looks nice especially with like the
slender face I assumed was photoshopped
to be a lot fairer feel like Thailand's
ideal skin is to look healthy so I think
that portrays into a lighter skin color
it still looks like me I see that I have
like I makeup on now my eyes are bigger
too I can still look like this like I
just need to straighten my hair and
drama lon
if this is what it takes for me to get
into Bollywood you know I'll try without
the bleach I'll like put eyeliner on and
straighten my hair I went in thinking
like this is gonna look nothing like me
but it looked a lot like me and I
realized that these standards are just
in my head like it transformed me into a
version of myself that looks exactly
like my mom I think it's often to see
myself in a different lens that also
made me appreciate myself more I'm very
proud to be one we have such a rich
culture I'm happy the way I am and I'm
so proud to be Thai and part of such a
colorful vibrant culture every Pakistani
woman I know is so different from the
other
you can't hold them down to this one
standard the only thing they have in
common is that they're very proud of
where they come